a small side note about the currently
ongoing controversy in the Chess World
where the 19 year old Grandmaster Hans
Neiman beat Magnus Carlson at the
sinkfield cup
after this Magnus for the first time
ever withdrew from the tournament
implying with a tweet that there may
have been cheating or at least something
Shady going on
folks like The Grandmaster hikarnakamura
fan the Flames of cheating accusations
and the internet made a bunch of
proposals on how the cheating could have
been done and arranged from the
ridiculous to the hilarious often both
Hans himself came out and said that he
has cheated before when he was 12 and
16. on random online games to jack up
his rating
but he said that he has never cheated in
person over the board Danny Ranch from
chess.com who I've spoken with may make
a statement in response to hans's claims
soon
folks like Grandmaster yakabuga spoke to
his experience training Hans Neiman and
has said that his memory and intuition
were quite brilliant
so as you see there's a lot of
perspectives on this chess base has a
good summary of The Saga that I'll link
in the description
also note that this is so quickly moving
that new stuff might come out between me
recording this and Publishing the
episode but I thought I'd mention this
anyway since the episode with the
bowtest sisters is a conversation about
Chess and was recorded shortly before
the controversy so we didn't talk about
it
I'm considering having Hans on this
podcast and also Magnus back on the
podcast maybe others like Hikaru or
folks from chess.com's anti-cheat staff
to discuss their really interesting
cheating detection algorithms
but I may also just stay out of it I
find just to be a beautiful game and the
chess Community full of fascinating
brilliant people and so I'll keep having
conversations like these about Chess
it's fun
my goal with this podcast and in general
as a human being is to increase the
amount of love in the world sometimes
that involves celebrating Brilliance and
Beauty in science in art in chess
sometimes it involves empathetic
conversations with controversial figures
that seek to understand not to ride
sometimes it involves standing against
the internet Lynch Mob as the chess
based article calls it to hear the story
of a human being who is under attack
even if it means I get attacked in the
process as well